Bonjour...
*rires*
Superbe intro, merci Micka
Aujourd'hui, nous sommes sur For Honor, non pas le jeu qui sort le 14 février
mais sur la bêta ouverte !
qui a lieu euh... bah ça ferme dans une heure voilà.
C'est une blaaaague !
Que Micka a aprécié, il a vraiment rigolé
*rires*
Donc la bêta dure 3 jours un truc comme ça et avec Mika on avait envie
euh de mettre des coups d'épées dans des gens
Y'a trois classes, y'a Vikings, je sais plus, et Samuraï
et nous on a pris Samuraï parce qu'on a un petit côté japonais
Konnichiwa
Micka :Moi c'est parce que j'aime bien le kebab, sauce samuraï
Ok c'est parti, mec on va jouer en dominion
et avec Micka on s'est dit on va faire les p*tes
on va camper sur un point.
On va vraiment camper un point et dès qu'un mec vient, on fait une embuscade
ça te plaît Micka ?
Micka : EMBUSCADE ?
Ouais
Ok Micka c'est parti, team Samuraï.
Vas-y j'te suis Micka, j'te vois !
Oh lala t'es en train d'te battre !
Eh ils sont là !
Ils sont là fais attention à toi Micka !
Tiens !
Il a plus d'vie, il part en courant !
Attends, où tu t'enfuis, où tu t'enfuis ?!
Hop là !
J'lai chassé !
Le bleu, force bleu samuraï !
On l'défonce, on l'défonce, on l'défonce !
Vas-y, j'te suis Micka.
Tu m'reconnais ? C'est moi qui ai une corbeille de linge sale sur la tête !
Moi j'ai une kippa sur la tête, si jamais.
Oh Micka, attention !
Il a pas aimé c'est un raciste !
Il est antisémite !
Vas-y je vais attaquer par le haut, j'attaque par le haut !
Et tiens !
On l'a démoli
Micka : Ah y'en a un nouveau, y'en a un nouveau !
Ok ok vas-y, vas-y j'attaque par le haut
Ah il part en courant vas-y Micka on l'suit, on, l'suit, on l'suit
On l'suit, on l'suit !
Viens lààà
Viens lààààà
Vie--
Il va se retourner fais gaffe il va faire mal
Vas-y je prends l'autre moi
Ok c'est bon j'en ai eu un
T'es mort ?
Oh il t'a démonté !
Oh je t'ai vengé !
Oh la la mon Dieu mais quel combat !
Micka : réanime moi ! Réanime moi !
Ah comment je fais ? Comment je fais ?
Vas-y, vas-y, vas-y, ouiiii
Oh y'a un mec ! Y'a un mec !
Y'a un mec !
Il fait le malin, il fait trop le fier
Il fait trop le fier.
Oh p*tain !
Aaah attends, attends !
Casse-toi !
P*taiiin
Ok c'est bon. Oh GG Micka !
Qui peut tester les samuraïs ?
Micka : Oh j'ai une flèche !
Ouais moi aussi, moi aussi je peux encore en-- mais en vrai-- OOOOH
Attends, j'env-- j'appelle les archers !
Ah m*rde, c'est passé à côté
Attends j'arrive, j'arrive, j'arrive
Ils sont deux, ils sont deux
Oh p*tain attends
Y'a un gars derrière moi
Ils sont bo-- ils sont venus à 3 Mickaaa
Micka c'est la fin !
J'me fais prendre en sandwich Micka !
Ok j'suis en mode vengeance !
J'suis hyper vénère, j'suis en mode vengeance mon gars
Oh j'en ai eu un !
Oh j'en ai eu DEUX !
Aide-moi, aide-moi, rez moi, rez moi
Micka : Non mais je rigole, j'suis mort
Oh mais t'es c*n
Eh Micka, on va retourner sur cette zone
Et on va reprendre ce qui nous revient de droit
Alors là on prend l'échelle, on prend l'échelle
La discrétion c'est avant tout prendre une échelle et arriver face à l'ennemi
Tain mais c'est, c'est un peu notre ter-ter quand même hein
Ah, on est là on est présent
Ooooh 'tain attention, attention !
On l'défonce, on l'défonce
Le mec c'était une balle de ping-pong
On p*tain on va les démolir
Y'en a un là, y'en a un là Micka, y'en a un là
Tiens !
Ok y'en a un qui est mort, le deuxième il est là il est hyper vénère
Tiiiens !
C'est gagné !
Attends j'te rez, je t'aime mon amour
Viens là
AAH !
Y'a des pions qui m'attaquent, c'est bon
Eh moi je m'en vais en haut hein
Oh l'bat*rd il attend !
Le mec il attend en haut de l'échelle quoi !
Regarde le !
Regarde regarde j'suis en train de troller un mec sur échelle
Alors, tu veux ma peau ?
Oh p*tain
Vas-y défonce-le, on l'défonce, on l'défonce
TIENS !
Campeur sal*pe !
Ça t'apprendra à camper p'tit enc*lé
Micka : J'pense qu'on a gagné
Bravo !
Oh j'suis premier !
C'est la première fois de ma vie que ça m'arrive
Vas-y partie suivante, c'est parti on est chaud !
Oh nooon
On est avec 2 bots et en face c'est 4 vrais mecs
Micka : Ah m*rde
Allez, allons-y c'est parti
Allez on va tout droit ou on passe par en haut ? On va tout droit
Dans la mêlée
Oh on va se faire démolir !
Attends, je vais me cacher là
Attire-les
J'vais me cacher derrière le mur ici
Ok j'te vois
Et là, embuscade !
Oh p*tain je vais mourir moi !
Oh p*tain ils sont 2, ils sont 2, ils sont 2, ils sont 2
AAAAAAH
J'suis obligé de courir mon gars !
Ils m'ont dé-mo-li
Ah y'en a un qui me suit Micka, y'en a un qui m'suit !
Hiiiii t'es où, t'es où Micka viens m'aider
T'es où ?!
T'es où ?
Y'en a un qui me suit !
Attends je vais lui faire une embuscade
CA T'APPRENDRA A ME SUIVRE FILS DE P*TE
Il m'suivait mec je lui ai tendu une embuscade
Oh p*tain y'en a un qui arrive
Oh p*tain y'en a deux, y'en a deux Micka je me barre
Oh p*tain ils arrivent, ils arrivent, ils arrivent
Micka ils arrivent
Arrête de taper Micka toiii p*taiiin
AH ! Pardon il m'a mis une gifle
Pardon pardon, tape-le
Oh non, Micka c'est la fin
Vas-y réveille-moi
Ooh merci
Oh c'es-- quel doux réveil
Oh bah oui, p'tit breakdance au sol on va pas s'mentir
Tiens ! Il est mort !
Allez suivant suivant suivant
Vas-y vas-y, b*ise-le b*ise-le
Y'en a un sur moi, y'en a un sur moi !
Attends j'ai un p'tit pouvoir
Ok je récupère de la vie j'arrive Micka
MAIS CASSE-TOI
Oh j'suis mort, j'suis mort, ils sont tous sur moi, j'suis mort
Allez Micka 'faut qu'on se regroupe
'Faut qu'on fasse un rush sur A viens
On fait le tour on va reprendre A
Attends je vais regarder s'il y a pas un mec derrière
Non c'est bon on n'est pas suivi
On va prendre A et dès qu'il y a un mec qui vient
ON L'EXPLOSE !
Vas-y vas-y, b*ise-le b*ise-le
Embuscade, embuscade !
B*ISE-LUI SA MÈRE !
C'est bon il est mort, il est mort, c'est bon, c'est bon
Micka : Et juste là y'a un truc à activer
MAIS MICKA
TU TE FAIS TAPER
TOUCHE PAS A MICKA !
Retourne sur le point A
Y'a un mec, y'a un mec
Micka : Ils sont tous en train de venir là
Adieu Micka ils sont 3, ils sont 3
Eh c'était un viol
Eh on était pas loin de gagner pour une team qui a 2 bots hein
Boh, j'me rassure comme je peux
Micka j'te prends 1V1
D'homme à homme
Micka : C'est moi qui te prends
Ne m'humilie pas devant ma communauté s'il-te-plaît
Oh j'ai trop peur
Allez vas-y, viens.
Micka : C'est pas une technique hein, pour de vrai
Non, tu regarderas pas les coups spéciaux Micka
Micka : Mais non mais j'ai ma souris qui euh...
Micka : Qui bug
Oh p*tain, oh p*tain !
Allez, ferme-la
Ferme ta g*eule
Viens t'battre (x5)
Viens t'battre (x4)
Micka : Attends j'ai vu un truc là-bas
Mais elle est pitoy---
Viens t'baaattre
ALLEZ
Micka : Ah non ! Je l'ai contrée !
Oh p*tain j'ai battu Micka, j'ai battu Micka
Allez allez, qui va gagner ? On se l'demande
Est-ce que ça va être serré ?
Micka : Oh j'ai testé un truc, fallait pas
Oh p*tain
Oh p*tain !
OH NON !
OH L'ERREUR !
Là il s'enflamme, là, là il va faire l'erreur
Oh non c'est moi qui l'ai faite !
P*tain quel duel, bien joué, bien joué
1 partout, 1 partout
Attention c'est euh, c'est 3 manches gagnantes hein
bien tenté, bien tenté
Oh p*tain oh wow wow eh remballe ta caisse là !
Oh non
OH NOOOON !
p*taiiin
Mais mon perso quand il est pas à vie mec
Il devient nul
Ouais je parle plus français tellement je rage
Allez allez allez 'faut gérer
Micka : Oh non !
Et hop !
Ça va Mickalow ?
Micka : J'ai fait exprès
Allez
C'est la belle
C'est la grande finale, c'est ce qu'on voulait voir dans cette vidéo :
Du beau jeu
Micka : Concernant tout ça là
Micka : On peut s'expliquer ou pas ?
Oh b*tard NOOOON
Micka : Non ! Mais j'étais en train de m'amuser !
Quoi ?!
Mais d'où tu t'amusais ?
Oh l'excuse !
Il faut toujours qu'il ait une excuse lui !
Tu veux pas juste dire "Bravo p*tain t'es trop fort" ?
Micka : Non, moi j'dis une prochaine et c'est celui qui gagne, qui gagne.
Et les-- voilà les amis c'est déjà la fin de cette vidéo
N'hésitez pas à l'aimer si ça vous a plu, merci Micka
de m'avoir rejoint et d'avoir perdu comme une énorme m*rde
Micka : Moi je veux bien faire exprès hein
N'hésitez pas à passer voir la chaîne de Micka
J'vous dis à bientôt dans une prochaine vidéo
Merci d'avoir regardé, portez vous bien
Ciao tout le monde !
SHLACK !